we have learnt about this process
differentiation right now quickly I'm
sure mrs. Lee's is managing this to you
but the verb differentiate it creates a
new function and what is that thing
called it's called the derivative right
so what you get out of this is the
derivative but please please please note
this is the noun differentiate is the
verb derive despite the way this word
looks derive is not the verb you are not
deriving I mean you might be but you
most of you are not okay we are
differentiating to arrive from a
function to its derivative which tells
us what what does the diminutive tell us
about a function it tells its gradient
right which is why we often call the
derivative the gradient function okay
now this idea of the derivative being
the gradient function is where we begin
it's our foundation but we quickly
realize that actually differentiation is
also useful for all kinds of other
things that has nothing to do with the
gradient function so it's a process that
can just be done to whatever function
you like and so we need an operator to
place the front out of this just like
you know taking logs is an operator log
of something or you know raising
something to a power or a square root so
these are all operators that like the
square root zone where did we first meet
the square root what do we why did we
care about it what kind of problems are
we trying to solve we're trying to solve
problems like this right so we're like
okay I know this I know this I can find
this but I require the square root right
now we began trying to solve this
problem but then we realize actually
square roots useful for all kinds of
other things that have nothing to do
with right angled triangles it's the
same deal here with the derivative okay
so how we begin this well we said if you
have some function f of X then it's
derivative f dash is equal to a
particular limit do you remember what
the limit was limit as H approaches zero
of what
I'll give you a clue it's a fraction 1/2
of X plus h you take away f of X and
what that's divided by is hey it's very
good ok
now you should have this and this should
be like imprinted into your memory ok
it's really important first principles
it's something we return to over and
over again every time you're going to
learn something new to differentiate at
the moment all you know how to
differentiate is polynomials every time
you learn how to differentiate a new
thing like say trig functions
Exponential's logs when we get there we
always come back to this that's why I
have called first principles ok but I
want you to remember because it's the
gradient function write this fraction
corresponds to gradient what is the
fraction of Graynor actually one of the
two components usually you don't
remember what are the two covers on the
top you got rise which is this guy right
that's your f of X f of X plus h the
difference of course is the rise and
then on the denominator you have the run
very good okay now this is long and
awkward though we don't need to go
through first principles every single
time if we have any kind of function
wrong color we have any kind of function
Y right we can write the derivative just
as Y - we can use this same notation ok
but I want to introduce to you a better
way of doing this I'm gonna objectively
say better because this - notation is
kind of useful because it's succinct if
it's not very descriptive doesn't tell
you for example what you're
differentiating with respect to like
that doesn't mean it into your thermo
because you've only ever differentiated
with respect to one thing like say X but
later on you'll need to differentiate
with respect to other things and this -
notation kind of lets you down okay so
here is the differential operator I'm
going to introduce if you have a
function for a function y right its
derivative
can be expressed in this way D on the X
Y okay now this thing here which I've
placed at the front of Y you should put
a big box around it and you should put
an arrow going from your heading to that
box because this thing is called the
differential operator it's just like log
right it's something which you apply to
something else okay it's a function of
its own that's why it doesn't make sense
you don't to write this down it doesn't
make sense to say this for example
because it's an operator it needs to
operate on something okay
DM DX is equal to it doesn't equal
anything right it's it's got to be x
stored be operated on something like
that right in the same way that this
doesn't mean anything five times nothing
equals something
it's an operator right multiplication is
an operator has to apply to something
okay so this is saying differentiate
this thing but as you can see here right
there's a parallel between thinking
about differentiation as an operator and
thinking about it as a function namely
gradient right I can write this thing
over here D on DX of Y I can write it as
a single thing it's really being applied
to this numerator is really being
applied to Y right so I can write this
with the D and the Y combined okay now
many of you have seen this before you've
accounted you're like oh yeah I
recognize that I've heard of this before
okay that's just another way of saying
the derivative right for all intents and
purposes yes but you have to be very
very careful with it okay let me say two
things about it number one what we love
about it what's so powerful is that it
preserves the original meaning of
differentiation the original meaning of
the derivative right because this D
stands for Delta right it's short for
Delta which we used we've been using in
science for years Delta of course means
change right so if Delta D just means
change then what dy means is change in
I'm gonna write this down could someone
change in Y right now we have a name for
that that's more succinct it's just rise
right that's what the change in
isu went up by this distance right DX
you would extend to mean change in X
which again we have another name for
this we just call it run okay what it
also preserves only move this over just
so it's a bit clearer what are also
preserves is the fact that in pretty
much every context that you're ever
going to look at it the derivative
functions just like a fraction in fact
you can multiply and divide by DX on dy
you could take the reciprocal of this
and get instead of dy DX you get DX on
dy as a whole separate derivative you
can treat this just like a fraction it's
important to note if you guys move
further into mathematics after here if
you do mathematics at university you
will learn that the derivative can't
actually always be treated just like a
fraction just like like 4/5 okay because
it's kind of not a fraction think back
look I've got it on the board and you
should have it as well think back to
what this fraction actually means it's
got a limit built into it right so for
example this denominator what would you
say it's equal to it's kind of equal to
zero right it's not really that's why we
use a limit okay but it behaves very
similar to zero so it's not like a
normal number we actually you know you
guys have done first principles you know
you do stuff up here in the numerator so
you can cancel the H out so you don't
have to worry about dividing by it
because it's kind of like zero we don't
like doing that in the same way if H is
approaching zero what happens to the
rise we know that denominator is going
towards zero what about the numerator
think about this as H gets smaller and
smaller and smaller well you know you're
actually had a right angle triangle here
but I wasn't clever enough to face it in
the correct direction if you have rise
and run and this part this you know this
little triangle models what's happening
on a larger function like that as run
gets smaller and smaller and smaller
what happens to rise it it also gets
smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller and smaller do you see that
right so this thing here isn't like a
normal fraction it's kind of like zero
on zero that's not meant to work is it
right so
you have to be careful with this object
for the significant number of you if you
go into a science degree or an
engineering degree you'll do first-year
mathematics and you'll learn you have to
treat this object with finesse and care
it's not just like this fraction okay
but for all intents and purposes over
the next two years you will treat it
just like a fraction you multiply by it
you'll take reciprocals you do all the
things you normally do two fractions as
well okay